[Musique]
ouais essayant de retourner en prison
dollars et livres de tournée pas Collins pistolet trop
vite sur le gaz ne me poursuivez pas mettez-le
comme ça Graham je suis un dur à cuire fais
moi une faveur il me reste trois jours là-dessus
probation quand vous avez cette arme sur
vous ne m'en parlez pas
déni plausible oh voulez-vous dire
frère
[Musique]
vous êtes un criminel condamné m.  Hoskins
tu es maintenant que jusqu'à preuve du contraire
je prouverai le contraire à tout moment tu
sais que tu n'as pas besoin d'agir dans le ghetto pour
traîner ici
nous devons nous débarrasser de miles vœux c'est
mon meilleur ami il va te remettre
en prison  ou il va te faire tuer,
ne me fais pas écrire pour ta dernière
semaine, le juge prolongera ton séjour
ici d'un an, c'est la vie dans laquelle nous
vivons depuis le début et tu sais
qui est coincé dans ce sol.
Je ne suis pas celui qui fait ça maintenant, chaque fois que tu viens autour de toi, les monstres me font me sentir comme un monstre dans ma propre ville, je ne vais pas te tuer